it's show time
oh my god
whatever he's paying you I'll double it
trust me you work for me now you're late
you're in the wrong place at the wrong
time
oh hang on let's go who the hell are you
what do you want with me it's me you
want beaver alone you have no idea you
don't want to know I got a bad feeling
about this
Wow we've got company don't do anything
stupid why tell me you know you're doing
what a minute stay out of this
check please you just don't get it do ya
you look like [ __ ] we got a situation
here I can explain what are you trying
to say what are you talking about stay
down no no my watch I trusted you
it's nowhere looks like Miss Myers who
do you think you are I own this city
follow me you got the wrong guy listen
about last night it's not what you think
okay you watch this let her go time to
take out the trash
keep the change follow that car let's do
this I can tell you I don't have to kill
you we had a deal
I just need one more minute we don't
have a minute she's dying right behind
me isn't she we can do this the easy way
or the hard way
I was born ready you bastard I'm just
getting started let's split up are you
thinking what I'm thinking
tell my wife I love her I should have
killed you when I had the chance don't
you die on me you don't have to do this
if I wanted you dead you'd already be
dead
this time it's personal don't let go
that's an order then sign up for this
sweet mother of God but we don't
negotiate with
terrorists government it's quiet a
little too quiet your father was a great
man I got a bad feeling about this so we
meet again I'm gonna blow this case wide
open I work alone
I got some rules I don't need a partner
you'll pay for this you're off the case
turn in your badge and your weapon don't
touch that button get me the president
this is it over this better be good
give me one good reason why I shouldn't
kill you right now is that all you got
is that the best you know if you hurt
one hair on her head I'm not leaving
without you that's impossible you look
like you've seen a ghost
that house burned down ten years ago
stop in my office get out of my office I
was doing my job
good job out there now where were we I
was about to ask you the same question
lock and load oh hey don't know whatever
you do don't look down I'm coming for
you that's more like it
yeah you you better run it's a trap this
ends No
you
you